[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola a todos ya todas
y ah
sí
todos
finalmente fue esa letra
la que hizo estallar la polémica
una noche del 2018
mientras estábamos pendientes de otros
debates
y de pronto escuchamos lesivo tardes
y la frase cayó como una piedra en el
cristal de una ventana
lenguaje inclusiva
mejor dicho no sexista
miren yo soy profesora de español
y conozco bien las reglas de mi idioma
dice que cuando digo todos
estoy incluyendo a toda la audiencia
sin embargo desde hace algunos años
suelo comenzar mis presentaciones
diciendo
bienvenidos y bienvenidas
alumnas y alumnos
porque con esa repetición innecesaria
gramaticalmente innecesaria
lo que estoy diciendo
lo que quiero decir
y que soy una mujer
que está atenta a las cuestiones de su
tiempo
que no vivo en un termo
que estoy al tanto de las miles de
mujeres
de los cientos de colectivos que
trabajan día a día
para lograr equidad en los vínculos
en el trato social en el contrato social
bueno
contrato social no tiene mucho que ver
con el tema así que miren volvamos al
lenguaje
volvamos al lenguaje seguramente como
hablantes de español habrán observado
que en español tenemos dos palabras para
referirnos al estado civil de las
mujeres
señoras
señoritas
y que en cambio tenemos una sola palabra
para referirnos al misterioso
el estado civil de los hombres
como si alguien a través del lenguaje se
hubiera tomado
no digo el derecho pero por lo menos el
atrevimiento de conocer el grado de
disponibilidad de las mujeres
bueno
el grado de disponibilidad de las
mujeres tampoco es el tema el tema es el
lenguaje así que volvamos al lenguaje
les propongo le propongo está
del inmenso campo léxico que tiene el
español
de las decenas de miles de palabras que
tiene el español les propongo que nos
concentremos en ese pequeño terrenito
que son los insultos
no lo vamos a decir no gracias gracias
lo vamos a decir porque claro
la mayoría de las palabras en las que
están pensando
son palabras que corresponden a la
categoría de
malas palabras
palabras que yo no diría desde este
escenario
son esas palabras que una cultura
reserva para aquellas cosas de las que
no quiere hablar
es decir lo que una cultura consigna
como el tabú
otra vez
pero el tabú tampoco tiene que ver con
el lenguaje sexista así que volvemos
donde estábamos unamos al lenguaje otra
vez
volvamos a los insultos
probablemente coincidirán conmigo
en que una vez que hemos agotado esa
larga lista de palabras hirientes
con que podemos insultar a alguien
sobre sus condiciones físicas mentales
todavía nos queda una injuria
que ni siquiera tiene que ver con las
condiciones de esa persona
sino con la conducta de su madre
qué nos pasó
que no pasó como es que teniendo decenas
de miles de palabras a nuestra
disposición
fuimos a elegir una vinculada a la vida
privada de las mujeres
para construir con ella uno de los
mayores insultos que podemos decirle a
una persona
como si la honra femenina
estuviera puesta ahí también
en un horizonte de vigilancia
y de visibilidad
al alcance también de otra palabra dura
como una piedra
bueno la honra femenina tampoco es el
tema
saben que es que va a ser difícil hablar
del lenguaje sin hablar sin hablar de
las cosas que están alrededor del
lenguaje
sin hablar de las cosas que nos pasan
como personas como grupo como sociedad
porque saben que la lengua no circula en
un vacío
la lengua no circula aislada de la
cultura y sus hablantes
la lengua no es ese conjunto de palabras
muertas en un diccionario
está viva
le corresponde a sus hablantes nos corre
por las venas
qué es una lengua
qué es una lengua sino un retazo de la
cultura un jirón del yo íntimo que se
agita cuando algo se agita en el entorno
social
yo suelo decirle a mis estudiantes que
el lenguaje se parece mucho a los
relojes
la mayoría de nosotros tiene uno en la
muñeca
en el celular en la casa a mano
hacemos uso del reloj lo consultamos
todo el tiempo queremos saber la hora
despertarnos por la mañana
pero pocas veces tenemos la curiosidad
de pensar cómo funciona
pocas veces tenemos la curiosidad de
darlo vuelta
para mirar como en su interior las
pequeñas piezas que lo componen están
articuladas entre sí
para producir un efecto que es la hora y
que nosotros tan naturalmente usamos
bueno con el lenguaje pasa algo similar
tenemos un vocabulario a mano más o
menos rico más o menos extenso
hacemos uso de él
lo usamos para comunicarnos todo el
tiempo
pero pocas veces tenemos la curiosidad
de darlo vuelta y mirarlo al trasluz
para mirar como en el revés de la trama
las pequeñas piezas que lo componen
desde las cortesías a los insultos
están articuladas entre sí
para producir un efecto
la naturalización de la forma en que nos
tratamos
las formas del trato del destrato o del
maltrato
y así
como el movimiento de las manecillas del
reloj están relacionadas con el
movimiento de la tierra en el universo
así también
cuando algo se mueve
en el lenguaje es porque algo se mueve
en ese pequeño universo a su alrededor
que es la cultura
vistas así quizás la ley lado
vistas en esta trama de lengua y de
cultura
quizás no son tres vocales sueltas ahí
peleándose entre ellas por apoderarse
del final de las palabras
quizás son más bien un síntoma
indicios que como este dedo índice
señalan una zona caliente de la cultura
así como en el universo ocurren cientos
de cosas de las que ni nos enteramos
en el lenguaje todos los días ocurre
algo
todos los días una palabra es herida de
muerte y ya no vuelve
todos los días una palabra se cae de
nuestras bocas
se va de nuestras vidas
dejamos de pronunciarla sin que nos
demos cuenta
y ya no vuelve
así nos pasó con la conjugación verbal
saben que hay ahí
saben que hay ahí el cadáver del futuro
imperfecto del indicativo
se nos murió hace años
en argentina nadie dice mañana iré a tu
casa
y decimos más bien mañana voy a ir a tu
y el futuro imperfecto se murió cuando
como donde porque no sé yo no estaba
pero su cadáver si hay tieso
a nadie le importa
y si quieren venido a preguntar por su
cadáver mucho menos es llevárselo
pero
pero tengo good news
porque todos los días llegan a nuestro
idioma palabras nuevas
vienen desde lejos
a veces hablando a otros idiomas
llegan a través de nuestras all in one
a veces con sus faith news
a meterse en nuestros trending topic
pero las amamos
[Aplausos]
las adoptamos las usamos a veces les
estoy leamos
las hacemos nuestras las apa y sanamos
y todos los años el diccionario de la
real academia les abre la puerta porque
ya son nuestras
pero ahora
ahora está llegando
la escandalosa letra
escándalo se escribe con él
está ahí
esta es la frontera del idioma
empujando esas fronteras
empujando los bordes los límites
como una inmigrante
mostrando en las aduanas sus
credenciales falsas
falsas credenciales para ingresar en el
sistema
está ahí
me preguntan
qué pasará con ella
bueno
pasará lo que siempre ha pasado desde
que la humanidad comenzó a hablar las
lenguas cambian
no de un día para otro
no por imposición de una minoría
prepotente
las lenguas cambian por la acumulación
de miles de minúsculos actos
actos a veces silenciosos entre
hablantes
actos que un día llegan a todas las
voces a todas las conciencias a todas
las bocas
y desde ahí recién desde ahí a la
centralidad legal del diccionario
me preguntan qué pasará con ella
es probable que se vuelva por donde ha
venido
dejando ahí su militancia en las aduanas
a otros signos
es probable que se vuelva por donde ha
venido
no sin antes habernos hecho comprender
que necesitamos palabras nuevas
para nombrar las nuevas subjetividades
que nos habitan
para nombrar los nuevos vínculos
quizás se vaya por donde ha venido
cuando comprendamos
que la piedra que una noche rompió el
cristal en la ventana
alejado ha dejado un enorme agujero
por donde podríamos asomarnos a ver qué
está pasando afuera del lenguaje
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah